good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toasted is a bright sunny
and sweaty [ __ ] day here in New Jack
said hey oh my god I so much sweat today
cuz like I was very ambitious and saw an
apartment like I viewed an apartment
before the toast like life before the
toast is not real
yeah there's no such thing no it was a
crazy ambitious thing for me to do it's
like PT bt PT totally before toast post
oh but a bt a tea
yeah I guess that would be it but no
nothing happens bt you like have to go
to the doctor or something well no in
case of emergency yeah um but welcome
back to the morning shows thank you for
joining us yesterday be a look charlie
good show yesterday you're really just
hoping to bleed into tooth Jay you know
I'm feeling good get those bleedy vibes
into Tuesday via town source Mitch how
you feel in on the winds into good
feelin good I really look sound like how
you feeling on the snitch cam good yeah
that's right that's right like to hear
the snitch cam sense for always be
snitch cam yes always be fishy we are
gonna talk a little bit about bachelor
in paradise but there's another episode
tonight and then the snatchler will be
hitting you on the podcast apps but we
did run into quite a little Tundra yeah
with this natural err yes our podcast
was taken down off of iTunes because you
know what we deserved it because we had
copyrighted material in our artwork
which has since been remediated so I'm
hoping it can get back up on iTunes by
tomorrow but in case that it doesn't
it's still available on Spotify and I
think you'd also listen to it on audio
boom calm like if need be
yeah do give you the link give you the
links tomorrow hopefully we're back up
and running because the snatchler was
just like snatching up the chart you
know the satchel was snatched off the
charts
yeah oh and then she was snatched I just
knocked her wig with not that it's a
good thing but like I do feel like
somewhat seen by like Warner Brothers
like coming for our podcast I just have
to say like the holding company of The
Bachelor came for our small little
podcast I agree it is so flattering
thank you for the recognition
like we're not worthy but we really
appreciate a are worthy time yeah check
it you know you're sounding you're so
I'm just I'm just humble like I'm a
humble girl
you're the way you say humble is very
humbling okay Airy
mumbling word not to bore everyone but I
think tendinitis in my left big toe um
let me tell us more I had tendonitis in
my thumb like two years ago when I told
a bunch of doctors to figure out why and
it was the worst pain I've ever
experienced in my life now I'm having it
in my toe and it's just it's not working
for me I got to be on my feet today I'm
a busy woman I'm sorry I think I'm the
face of tendonitis honestly like you
know how I'm Hulsey is the face of enemy
to Isis yes and Yolanda Hadid is the
face of Lyme disease I am the face of
tendonitis I understand and soon to be
gout ah neat scout it's just my big toe
whoa isn't what it feels like yeah I
know someone who has God I'm gonna ask
doubt is just so crazy watch an episode
of Royal Pains oh my god I'm really
feeling like I've got now but you don't
eat super rich no I eat like macapa says
yeah it's the Kings is easy you don't
need like a king honestly you eat like a
sorry person no it's like caviar and
champagne yeah and like egg yolk yeah no
I don't [ __ ] with that yeah you know
what I'm thinking he's really feeling
Gaudi Gaudi vibes only Doughty vibes
only new merch
[Laughter]
anyways hey everyone welcome to the show
okay um what's good I feel like not a
lot happened since yesterday so I don't
have much to recap you guys on just you
know being a mom of one such rewarding
work such a rewarding work we did a
super-fun patron episode this is really
like patreon heavy week because one I
put up my full wedding extended video
trailer on the patreon which we spoke
about on our phn episode but it's just
so brave of you like it's just I feel
like for weddings like I spread myself
like I literally showed my vagina to the
world for my wedding but I didn't
release my video just because like that
is like so intimate you know yeah no you
did it was super personal but like that
was back when we didn't have a patron I
just I love our patrons and like
everyone really wanted this video and I
was happy to share it and I was really
just so glad that everyone's of it
because I had such a pit um then
yesterday we recorded a super-fun new
creative episode in episode where we
combed through the newspaper and talked
about all of the like craziest weirdest
funniest stories we read our horoscopes
we really we went through everything
except the sports section to back cover
to cover and I think it was filled with
interesting factoids I really do then
today we have our Asbury Park behind
this
episode growing up I've been working on
the content its premium it's a lot like
a 30-minute vlog
yeah it's super Bhagat actually been
watching fellow vloggers to learn the
art of the vlog like who what bloggers
do love Lauren Elizabeth of course only
Hager
but I've learned a lot for you to watch
olivia jade clogs i hope to comes back
soon
oh I've watched some of hers ya know cuz
all the b-roll and maybe she had a
camera I think so I might be able to be
ready to take my vlogging to the next
level you should really be like a
vlogger youtuber yeah but I would like
to do it for the show like I like this
level of we have so many channels in
which we post content like we cannot
take on another we need not be adding
another and then also cloudy and I think
this weekend we decided our filming our
I have a pit about it I haven't paid
about it to but drunk get ready with us
we're gonna model it after the clubbing
Kyle um but just like probably a little
bit lower budget I don't know if we'll
have like craft services yeah um but I
haven't paid about it's like I hate
getting drunk like unnecessarily do you
know what I mean so my answer after
Saturday night before the concert like
Saturday afternoon and then we'll go to
a concert and I think that's a good way
to expend our energy I think that's
actually a great idea so it's gonna be a
fun month for the patrons head over to
patreon.com/scishow moring toast to get
involved get the [ __ ] involved just like
another personal life update that I
really was excited to share with
everyone is that my husband shaved his
entire face thank God I didn't shave it
but I said let's have a little fun Wow
okay standing ovation I said let's have
a little fun while shaving so he shaved
the sides of the face and had like a
goatee and moustache in which he left on
for far too long like I would have never
suggested this fun little game if I knew
he was gonna take it like - crazy lanes
and he looked just like John four afro
and like now everyone just who says we
look like Jon Favreau and Ricky like
like really had something to like him
doing that makes you look more like
Ricki Lake no I know what it's like I'm
just sure I was at home working I'm like
don't get me involved and he's changing
tomorrow then he shaved the chin and
just left the moustache like as a joke
and then he was running around quoting
Lumiere ladies and gentlemen is with
greatest blieden she was pleasure and he
slept with it and he was like trying to
kiss before I met him like don't even
touch me and then this morning it is all
gone and he looks so great that's
exciting well he was here on this show
with the beard so I feel like the
toasters are really involved in the
Genesis
happened was that he was really taking
this beard like all the way and he went
to a beard like stylist and they like
trimmed it and shaved it and it made it
look just like so much like a beard that
it I hated it like I liked him like I
didn't mind it when it was so unkept cuz
like i didn't even realize that it was a
beard but when it was like fully shaved
trimmed with the sideburns I'm like oh
this is a beard it has to go and how do
we go I didn't like who he was becoming
with the beard you know it's oh my god
to do what a way to put it it changes it
was changing him and not for the better
I like I like a barefaced been me too I
like his personality like the bare skin
like don't muck it up and every time he
was on stories it's the beard oh yes he
was being crazy I had to smash it down
it was like the beard was like
invigorating him anyways story and it
was just too much for me it was firing
him up
it was hiring him up it was the it was
gas lighting ya know like the kerosene
uh yeah whatever there's something
there's something anyways cheating it's
time because I think it could be time
it's thinking what everyone feels ready
I mean I feel I feel as ready as I can
be given the morning that I've had
understood well without further ado it
is time for the fat side stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast so
it's time for service and I I don't want
to upset you because like I know you
guys have like had a super hard week and
like you're just going through a lot at
this time but please I'm literally
begging you from the bottom of my soul
it just let me tell you that's today's
episode is brought to you by Facebook
watch the real world's Atlanta please
tell us the morning toast is brought to
you by MTV's the real world Atlanta
streaming now only on Facebook watch the
original reality show is back and
streaming now only with Facebook watch
MTV's the real world Atlanta is the next
story true story of seven strangers
picked to live in a house and have their
lives
hook up screw-ups apologies fights tears
and voices streamed exclusively on
Facebook watch it's the return of the
first unscripted reality show in TV
history that tackle gender race AIDS
taboo life death addiction connection
acceptance and reality and it's being
reinvented MTV's the real world Atlanta
is an all-new reality experience of
content dropping daily and new episodes
every Thursday find out what happens
when the next generation stops being
polite and starts getting really on in
facebook click on the facebook watch
icon in search at the real world on
watch MTV's the real world Atlanta
streaming now
on Facebook watch it's a new episodes
drop every Thursday catch up now I've
been watching them because I did a
partnership with the real world and I
got to see the first episode super early
on it's actually it's [ __ ] compelling
[ __ ] it is compelling [ __ ]
it's a crazies what happens when people
stop being polite and start getting real
and you stay there for three months like
I would die that's [ __ ] crazy it's
torturous well at least they're becoming
famous right yes so true okay first
story a little exciting news for the
ladies out there and gentlemen Harry
Styles shirtless Rolling Stone cover
sends fans margo and claudia us right
into a frenzy truly friends truly frenzy
Harry Styles has left fans drooling
Rolling Stone magazine unveiled its
upcoming cover featuring a shirtless
Stiles and fans of the crooner and his
old band One Direction went into a tizzy
that is the best way to describe it I
was a party I was in a tizzy I was it
freaking out the cover features the 25
year old flaunting his pearly whites as
he leans into the camera showing off his
various tattoos fans couldn't seem to
contain their excitement or yeah so this
is exciting
well this is exciting just because like
I feel like you don't pose on the cover
of a magazine like when you have nothing
going on it makes me think that now the
media train is like starting to turn
like something will happen I mean
obviously my vagina wants it to be a one
direction reboot but methinks it might
be like an HSA ths to people so I'm like
spotted filming a music video okay okay
it's good but I just I really like I
feel like One Direction has been super
patient the fans have been really
patient like we haven't asked we let
them all do their thing but if you think
about it it's been like five years ago
and we gave the Jonas Brothers ten well
because I don't the Jonas Brothers broke
up they didn't go on hiatus like the One
Direction split up with the message
being we will get back together
eventually the Jonas Brothers was like
we're done and they never left us
hopeful as a 1d sin and I'm not even at
the top of the Santos Ratheon list I I'm
I'm okay to give them some more time I'm
sure you have to think about the
expiration date on a boyband I don't
know how
jazz I'm gonna be for forty year old one
direction I am I don't know I'm I'll be
jazz for thirty year-old one direction
where it's like they're still seeing the
same songs but it'll have more of a less
of a pop vibe but it'll just be good
music well that's what I wanted to say
was something we talked
last week my frustration with one
direction and when watching their
documentary and just like how they all
went on after one direction it's like
they've regarded their music as on One
Direction it's like not being serious
enough agreed I think if they're smart
and they seem to be now they know that
there were actually some really good
songs in there and they weren't
releasing out they went album tour album
tour like they were just really seeing
music for the sake of never not being
like really seen your music which was
silly like I could have used less music
from them but just more filtered out
music like they just had songs on albums
two complete albums when like they were
really good songs on that album but like
it was surrounded by a bunch of water
down yeah right
so I could I just want to impress like
when they do come back together like I
don't want them to think that the music
they were releasing as one direction was
bad because it was really good I know I
think however they come back together
it's inherently gonna be different
they're not the x-factor kids those
x-factor in general like you're signed
into contracts that like you have to be
producing this place you probably don't
even make that much money from it I
remember when fifth harmony was like
getting pretty popular they said they
we're still shopping at forever 21 like
they're not as rich as they say cuz also
they're making such little money because
of those contracts and then they're also
splitting it by five right so I think
when one becomes back it'll be in a
different format like now they have
agents and managers and like they know
what they're doing and some of that will
be like we're not putting out music to
put out music right now and they when
and if they get back together like they
will be a cash machine yeah because they
were a cash machine for the labels like
they were I don't think they were even
making that much money when they were in
one direction but they were generating
so much revenue for like four labels for
venues like when they are now like
they're famous enough to like make their
own deals like they're gonna be so
[ __ ] rich yeah they're I look forward
to that for them also like their fans
are getting older having jobs like I'm
ready to spend like I used to be in
college I didn't know I I couldn't spend
money on the merger right that's why
don't you share but like I want one now
right that's like with the Jonas
Brothers I feel like they actually might
be more successful now money-wise than
they were before because the the kids
that they were singing to back then had
to rely on their parents to get them
tickets their parents to get their merch
their parents to show up to CD signings
whereas like the Jonas Brothers fans now
are really young but like there oh gee
fanbase is us like we have disposable
income to buy tickets yes but I think
there's probably some marketers out
there who could tell you exactly who's
richer kids with their parents money or
people like young professionals that are
making money yeah
they can spend their own money but it's
not like parentless young professionals
have more freedom with their money but
they have probably less disposable
income than a parent spending money on
their kid yeah that's interesting and
like parents will spend that money on
their kids yeah make them happy but it's
just more fun to be a fan of someone
like when you have your own bank account
yeah when you can buy your concert
tickets you decide where you're gonna
sit right and like when we work like
kids these days just go to concerts like
all the time but like when we were kids
at concerts we're the biggest deal and
it's crazy because now we actually I
think in the next week I'm going like
four free concerts uh we go to so many
concerts because they make us like so
happy but growing up it was a huge deal
like to get your parents not only buy
your ticket but they have to go good
together they have to sit through this
crap so I'm gonna ask my mom to come to
something that I'm gonna be like
embarrassed also that I like it to drive
you there too and like if you're living
when when we were in when living in the
suburbs NASA call seems like an hour oh
yeah it's like it was a huge undertaking
I feel like it's not anymore I don't
know why I'm a because like so many more
people are going on tour like uber yeah
there's just so many ways like for it to
be different now but like I always feel
like really upset that like a lot of my
stanwood like childhood like I never
went to read Taylor Swift concert when
like I was fully into bit like a
developed sand but I just wasn't
financially independent or like really
independent in any other way it was your
cross to marry you're making up for it
now though no I am but like it's just
San culture which really serve I crave
all around kids is so limiting you know
you never think about that yeah I think
that the labels do you think about it
they're like okay parents they probably
have market research that are like
parents will spend this much on their
child and they will drive 30 minutes
yeah and then they figure it out from
there so we should work for a label or
some [ __ ] no I know
I think we're cracking the codes what do
you think counselor snitch
as the house Tanis breath I just hope
that Zayn isn't part of the reunion I
hope so too
I mean I don't think he will be but and
I I'm not upset about it well a concert
counselors named Britney Spears Britney
Spears remember that
Oh circus yeah we saw Britney Spears at
Circus concert Madison Square Garden she
lips saying her way through it was Emma
Street yeah remember that it was very
strange
was your first concert John Mayer
shockingly I chose speech which is such
a [ __ ] vibe yeah well I was like
twelve wait dance my first concert I
don't was either John Mayer concert now
was either Britney Spears concert yes
but that wouldn't have been your first
beer already because it was my first we
yeah I'm gonna my memory it's awful I
think it was Hannah Montana best of both
worlds out now oh I think it was glee no
no that was we were in high school yeah
we did you see best of both worlds
wheeze yes no we saw her crazy one she
went she was insane no no no we saw at
Nassau Coliseum the one where like it
was best of both world she did Hannah
and mine was not Hannah she was not
Hannah she was can't be tamed oh yeah
Wow so lucky of us to have seen that
honestly the hardest part about having
dementia is like I spent all this money
on tickets and I don't remember him yeah
that's why you snatched em can't be
tamed yeah remember she's on the
motorcycle in the in the sky yeah yeah
and I also remember like we left at the
Encore and she played something and we
actually waited because we loved that
song maybe best of both worlds whatever
I can't remember first concert I've ever
been to that's so sad it's so sad me I
used to tell people it was John Mayer
because I think it was you in a Lydia's
for this concert but I don't think that
it was we saw glee growing up in high
school that's so late yeah that was late
yeah I would have to have been a concert
that you saw before we moved to the city
but you would have been in seventh grade
what did you'd like who did you hang out
with what about your friends think of
your your middle school friends Oh Lord
to him anymore before they dumped you
you guys concert with them no okay I
feel like my first concert wasn't in
school is that weird no cuz mine your
first concert couldn't have been
snitch's you're four years older than
her three years older but I don't really
ever remember going to a concert like
without my family you know what I mean
now I remember
wow that's so sad really sad okay
next story it's splitsville for Katie
Holmes and Jamie Foxx who had split
after six years of dating and I was
chucking part about this is that they
were together for six years right and
that they really hit it very well for
like four years because I feel like I've
known about them for for about two yeah
they've been taken a relationship a bit
more public in recent months but they've
ended their six-year romance people
confirms quote Jamie and Katie split a
music entertainment source tells people
the couple parted ways in May Oh the
couple has been linked since 2013 though
they've never officially confirmed their
ultra private relationship rep for both
actors had no immediate comment news of
their split comes three days after Fox
was spotted holding hands with singer
celibate on Friday night as the two left
Bootsy bellows nightclub in LA okay so I
guess it looks like he's cheating on her
meanwhile
okay so now is the time to let you know
they're so secretive like a dude and it
like when they when every news outlet
reported at the exact same time that
they had broken up I'm sick this is so
unlike them to release a statement like
after just having broken up but it
actually makes sense that they broke up
in May and now he's moving on so they
had to have broken up you know yeah they
really were so successful at being so
private and it makes you think like
people can do that yes they really want
to so they just don't want to write but
they just want to like pretend like they
do want it right like I also saw story
today that I didn't um choose that that
was like a page six asleep or something
was like Miley Cyrus and Caitlin were
literally having sex in public and like
a West Hollywood club it sends like
alright so I think they're not trying to
be private no but I hate when
celebrities like do things like that and
then like demand it like tweet like it's
just what I perhaps say like yeah you
don't if you want your privacy like talk
to Katie Holmes ya know I'm a celebrity
like wannabe and I just don't want my
privacy yeah like I I'm just putting it
out there so when I do become huge well
I think she seems like she's in a good
place she like makes me she she made
really sad when you think about her life
um and like how she got here from like
she really like was flung on the scene
Dawson's Creek like everyone wanted a
piece of her she could have been like
her life would have been so different if
she didn't start dating Tom Cruise but
she also likes now she's a list and I
think she's forever a list wears when
she started dating Tom Cruise she was
she was like man teeny bopper like she
was a you know just another teeny
actress yeah I think that I think she
would still probably would have ended up
a list but she would have had to work
her way there like through roles cuz she
was really I don't think sighs dog would
have ever ended up at the Met Gala oh
the Met Gala you know what you think
about her contemporaries Busy Philipps
was on Dawson's Creek yeah right you
know I was watching exhibitor week I
think I made that out but no it's a city
that generally just pain generation
james Van Der Beek Busy Philipps they're
not at the Met Gala I was watching TV I
didn't Williams she's was she on
Dawson's Creek yeah I was watching you
at The Bachelor and I was watching live
with commercials and I saw two
back-to-back commercials with Busy
Philipps in it old navy and Olay
Wow and I know they won she had picture
knows for a second it was very weird I
was a president edit that out
intentionally yeah I think she was like
no like she was rubbing cream and they
literally only got the part where she
was rubbing like right in around
by her national that's weird it was like
a weird thing that they definitely
should have edited but it's like that
show as much as it wasn't a success like
really kind of halted her to another
level like I don't think before her TV
showed would she ever have been
back-to-back national campaign
commercials yeah so I think overall it's
a success because it's it's a launching
I mean and by the way like having a TV
show even if it gets canceled like as
someone who like Busy Philipps was never
meant to be a daytime television was an
actress you know and so like she really
earned herself a TV show just by being
funny and having a good Instagram like
and even though it got cancelled like
that is a success I feel like she's
talking about it now like on her
Instagram like the big failure of her
career but like no that's a big success
if you had a hundred TV show so you're
not gonna really cute say you had a Kim
Kardashian on your show like success
agreed look if I got a TV show like and
it got canceled like I would not be
embarrassed got a [ __ ] TV show you
had like one year of five nights a week
like I would just watch him and repay
for the rest of my life and I'd be so
tired five minutes a week it's like
super hard it's a lot of work like this
for real TV like the production takes
all day like I'd be tired I'd take some
time off and I mean look so grateful
like I've been seeing all these articles
that's like PC Phillips wants to know
more about why her TV show was canceled
well I think there's a really only one
reason TV shows get canceled that's cuz
like lack of ratings um and just like be
grateful like that sounds amazing yeah
you did it it's it's better to have
something in lost it than to never have
had it at all completely as some people
who have never had it at all busy be
grateful okay next story is actually
really shocking to me you guys didn't
seem so surprised but Billy Eilish is
bad guy hits number one on the Billboard
Hot 100
dethroning lil NAS X's old town road
after a record 19 weeks on top that's
crazy and it's also crazy that the song
that dethroned it is a song that like as
someone who's very immersed in pop
culture I don't think I've ever heard in
full in full maybe not be you know this
out in fact doodoo doodoo
it sounds like an arcade no it's like
see it looked three people three people
who are like pop culture fanatics we do
it as a full-time job and we don't even
know this song in full that's like the
power of the teeny boppers
I don't usually rings Justin Bieber like
congratulate her on his instagram story
and like it really not to make
everything about Taylor Swift but it
reminded me of something Taylor Swift
once said because he said congrats Billy
looks so happy to have been a part of
your history to been a part of history
like really including himself what did
he do oh he remixed it like he didn't
know she's just
mrs. being like a Justin Bieber number
no that was he they came out the song
she released a song with him on a verse
yes not the one that's like Billy Ray
tweeting at will not okay I mean it just
was a little like there will be men who
try and take I know what's the what's
the phrase you credit for your favor
your fame and your accomplishments and
that's just what it sounded like but
it's also like Mason Ramsey tweeting at
lil not she was like I'm the last
iteration of it still cute we just don't
like Justin Beiber no I'm not Justin
Bieber I actually really like him in
Haley I like him in Haley but I don't
like him just like makes me feel weird
and I feel like everything he posts on
Instagram he doesn't like know he's
posting dude I mean yeah I agree like he
sat on his phone and things yeah like
he's an accident
he's definitely weird I really like him
in Haley like super growing on me me too
um and she's like the most beautiful
woman in the world and it's really sad
that it took her like having to marry
like the most famous person in the world
for people to realize have cuz I always
knew she was pretty but it's really
frustrating cuz I still don't think
people realize that like she's
technically a model yet she still gets
no work because she's so short
she's our height I feel like height
doesn't matter anymore unless you're
walking in a fashion show anyway yeah
and she said she's never doing it again
she literally made it her story because
she was like I don't know how to walk I
also still don't think I've ever heard
her speak I have in her 73 questions and
she was like so soft-spoken and just
like literally if I touched her she
would break that's great she was just so
fragile that's how I felt about Sophia
Ricci until the video I had never heard
her speak no me neither but once I heard
her talk I'm like oh you could take a
punch in the face you wouldn't you
wouldn't be broken you know she yeah
she's built tough-looking Ford I think
she is built tough like a Ford you got
to be its first Scott and everything and
she she literally this is 19 year old
when she met him like changed him yeah I
was already something man stepped in his
ways their relationship is like 99% I
love but like the one percent where it's
like she literally looks like his child
yeah is like so [ __ ] creepy but I
really like them
I watched for bit like Disick um and I
thought it was interesting like there's
a lot of characters besides Scott Manny
and the girl that like not Willa the
girl brunette girl who lives in his
house and like works for him like is
really annoying I don't know her name I
don't know which one she's just like all
up in his business like real
just trying to say stuff that would be
like funny on TV she was really annoying
me I think they'll figure out who's well
like I don't like Israelis fighting was
hilarious oh but I didn't see that
episode but I don't like his partner his
immediate partner who he like does the
deals with because he talks too much
oh and it's like flip it like Disick not
like flip it like partner ya know but
it's super interesting and Scott like
really definitely knows what he's
talking about and what's so crazy and
you made this call it's like this show
should have been to flip it like
Kourtney Disick uh-huh you know when he
needed a decorator like Kourtney is a
decorator she's actually an incredible
decorator she was in Architectural
Digest so I don't know if she's like
actually just that stupid that she
didn't do it or just that major burn
yeah you know yeah and and I don't know
which ones ever remember those episodes
like a bunch of seasons ago where they
were driving around town and he was four
years ago he was already starting to
develop but he was like we could be a
team like you do designs and then she
was like okay and then she was like
actually like I'm gonna do it on my own
so dumb then she does do you agree like
I actually I like Williford and I
definitely want to be bad but a few a
great hurts style it's just it's just
not my style you know each I agree a
little too leafy yes a little too
minimal next up some good news Florida
Georgia line's Tyler Hubbard and wife
Haley welcomed baby boy very cute
Hubbard party of four FTL's Tyler
Hubbard welcomed the second child a baby
boy named Luca Reed with his wife Hayley
on Monday in Nashville people confirmed
Hayley was absolutely amazing throughout
the whole labor she was so patient
positive and strong she honestly made it
look easy proud dad Tyler gushed baby
was born at 3:40 a.m. waiting at 8
pounds 11 ounces and measured at 20.5
inches long I just like live for like
the wives of country music men because
they really have like created an
industry for themselves where they're
all like lifestyle Pinterest bloggers
with like RNG flow and they take
pictures and fields and they make money
while their husbands are on the road but
I just like I want to be one I and if I
can't be one I want a Real Housewives of
Nashville where you get these good
premium people oh my god okay let's
catch the Real Housewives of Nashville
the two FGL girls Britney and Hayley and
Shay's wives could I don't live for
they're in scrub I'm not gonna lie yeah
but like they're Oh probably leave it
all Dean Brittney audio Hawk is like
she's like the agent she's
the new Jen yes she would be like the
youngest one who like they would all be
like you're so immature
you know rush now Lauren bushnell wait
this great [ __ ] show I don't know if
they would do it
some of the women don't need it you know
what I mean you know I think some of
them are like probably too private to do
it but I think I think Brittany Kelly
would love it Brian Kelly's bright from
Florida Georgia like she has a business
that she would love to promote Lauren B
would like it I think Nika would do it
so maybe it's not Real Housewives then
maybe it's just like but it would need
to be on Bravo because anytime see
himself tries to do a reality show like
it doesn't work I see like wags it has
to be back on a or Bravo but Tory term
know a different name yeah that has to
be the concept she would like pitch the
show I actually am feeling really
passionate about is I I have to believe
that someone's thought of it and it
didn't happen for a reason like I think
the reason would be like that Trisha
Yearwood is it down you know yeah but
I'm like she's right for the show no she
wouldn't I think Brittany Aldean would
be down and she likes probably the
biggest name and she would be I feel
like the center of the group where it's
like she's really connected to like the
old school like Luke Bryan's wife
because Jason Aldean is like so like
cemented in his career but she's also
like new way but she's an Instagram you
know yeah and I mean if Barbie Blake had
played her cards right it could have
been her she could have seen herself on
wags part two who do we talk to about
getting the show off the ground like I
would literally love to be a producer
yeah and I don't want to be on it cuz I
don't fit the mold but like I think I
have a lot of good ideas yeah because I
come down come to town they see the toes
v yeah oh my god I actually feel I think
I'm really on to something
yeah well there's something to see this
steal your idea and you're not gonna get
it what do we know in in TV we know some
people some people will talk to our team
well yeah and just as you have any
biggest business card printed up
I caught ray attorney-at-law and exactly
the producer of The Real Housewives of
Nashville
yeah we're the real what would they be
if they're not housewives because maybe
they're not all housewives maybe they
don't want to be a real hot size
franchise and like ladies of Nashville
how ladies of London was like love that
you know that but maybe not ladies like
how girls of Nashville like chicks of
gnash know they know that's so tacky
yeah gals of Nashville I like that
print that on my business card from
mister print oh do it where you can
upload your own designer start with one
of their professionally designed options
they use only carefully selected inks
and responsibly sourced paper socks
dozens of design
that are just right for your business so
I've used Vistaprint over the many years
of just so you know like being a fake
businesswoman and the best part is that
they're so cheap because I could get
five hundred and then I realized I
couldn't really need them because I
don't really have a job but there were
only $9.99 so like I'm fine you know but
you do need them because I don't think
there's anything worse in this world and
when someone asks you to your card and
you don't have one no it's like that's
like things you have a job and you're
like no juvett card no sorry I'm a piece
cheese but that's basically what you're
saying and there's no sorry I don't like
opportunities right no I don't want your
money thanks I'm good I have enough this
different wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners with their 500
high-quality custom business cards
starting at $9.99 use code toast at
vistaprint.com
that's code TOA st at vistaprint.com
toast at VI sta print.com I honestly
think that some of you could benefit
from a business card read that that's
all I'm saying yeah I some of you don't
have a business card and HS definitely
we also got some other good suggestions
on wise okay Thomas writes wife or oh
yes of course
he's so premium to Jesse James Decker
who's no stranger to reality team I
don't think I don't think it's right for
him now okay
Nicole kitchen yes oh my god she would
never but like that TV show is
everything everything everything oh my
god we got to make it happen I would be
here two million dollars a season it's
good enough for Denise Richards it's
good enough for him to call him in oh my
god this I'm just getting so excited
wait speaking of country music country
wives people are suggesting for a name
love it me Joe
speaking of country music our fifth and
final stories a little country news a
little country knows she's back Carrie
Underwood hosts the CMA Awards with
Dolly Parton and Reba McEntire the CMA
Awards are swishing things up this year
on Monday the Country Music Association
announced that Carrie Underwood would
once again return to host but instead of
decade-long mainstay Brad Paisley she'll
be home host joined by guest host and
country icons Reba McEntire and Dolly
Parton in a new women driven initiative
and maybe though coach the host of the
morning toast well I just started
thinking that CMA Awards are coming up
and for the third consecutive year
second no third third for the third
consecutive year in a row we have to be
there so we will leave I will get on the
paperwork of you know media credentials
because it's too important it's really
the best day of the year it's the best
it's gonna be like the craziest week for
me because I have a wedding in Morocco
that weekend and then TMA words are
Wednesday okay so maybe I'll just like
fly straight to Nashville and then I'm
on tour that weekend like but I have to
make it happen but are there flights
from Morocco to Nashville probably be
Casablanca to JFK and then JFK - Oh got
it
so that's terrible yeah but even last
year when we went to the CMAs it was the
busiest week and then we had the device
I just threw a wrench in my life like we
went from a linnaeus Bachelorette to
Nashville it was pouring rain remember
the Toyota CMA Awards wait to walk
through Music Row my god yes with our
shoes off obesity week yes and then then
we went divinely to Pittsburgh from
Pittsburgh to New York New York I went
to Dallas from Dallas I went to Utah for
Thanksgiving it was a crazy week but
November's like always a crazy time and
whether I have to walk or crawl there
I'm going to the zoo my words of course
we will be there we will I didn't wait
what are we gonna wear I don't know we
should get like now that we've thought
about it we usually like I'm always like
forgetting the month before like putting
in credentials and trying to find like
media people to produce the show but now
that we're like fully on top of it three
months in advance we should get like
outfits made oh like really country like
Kacey Musgraves like yeehaw that's like
not stupid he's watching we don't want
to offend no but I want like sparkly
boots you should wear a retro feet just
with Cowboys it's done oh my god look
over the knee cowboy boots cool I know
do you think they make those yeah I'm
gonna who was a girl from Patrick rider
who was here um Layla or she should make
us outfits Thank You Dallas
oh my god wait that's actually a good
idea yeah okay done Margo ready John
sweet well that's exciting I mean sad
for Brad Paisley but this seems like an
iconic show and was like oh what it Brad
Paisley do like it was some sort of bad
blood but then I realized country music
has been like really getting hounded by
especially the women in country for not
like being you know equal pay the men
just like dominate everything so I don't
think Brad Paisley did anything wrong I
just think it's not a good luck for them
to have a man hosting yeah no I think
they're switching things up and we were
just saying like two weeks ago when will
they switch it up if and I like how we
were speculating because I guess this is
just how we're programmed to be so ages
that they were gonna go with someone
yeah but they went with two people who
are older I love it Reba's just Reba is
hosted something once before and she was
great at it a CMS yes I get confused ACM
CMA like it's literally the same letters
yeah it's just another opportunity for
us to enjoy ourselves
can you believe that I'm where's your
wedding in Morocco no I can't
I'm like I've never been I've like I'm
just like nervous like I'm not really
like a traveler you know none of us
really are this is like in my opinion
like a little ADIS
yeah I just don't think I would ever
have another opportunity to go to
Marrakesh and I just feel like I'm gonna
be Sex in the City you will be and I
will be Miranda and I will be proud of
it that'll be that'll be super cool yeah
where they hear all about it on the CMA
Awards red carpet I know like two days
later that's gonna be such a crazy week
I'm very excited maybe you'll get some
cool garbs in Morocco that you could
wear this honestly this outfit I'm
wearing right now is very Moroccan is it
is it on no it's like a print I guess if
it were in the caftan maybe if I was
wearing Felix Grey glasses with it you
think I would be like a little bit more
Moroccan I don't know if you'd be more
Moroccan but you definitely be doing
better for your eyes and definitely be
more stylin while in and also be living
it up in the city you may not realize it
but the average American blast their
eyes with bright screens for 11 hours a
day I always check my screen time let's
check it right now oh my god screen time
is like the worst app that ever happened
to me do you guys want to know my
average phone time yeah over the last 7
days let's see oh man screen time 10
hours what's yours uh 4 hours and 38
minutes per day Oh mad you're a freak
Margo that's crazy that's nothing what's
yours okay
seven hours oh okay oh my god I can't
without more demarco that's really weird
and it's so bad for my eyes and that's I
definitely know that's why I got like
optical migraines because I'm like never
protecting my eyes when you consider how
much your day were Rob's around your
device it seems so crazy the majority of
Americans have with tired dry eyes
blurry vision or headaches caused by
screens if this sounds familiar Felix
great glasses are for you
I got Felix wear glasses like two months
ago when I use them now before bed when
like I'm scrolling my phone and when I'm
watching two hours of treacherous
bachelor in paradise and I definitely
feel like I'm going to bed with less
headaches and just like less dizziness
Ben also is making the transition over
to Felix gray and I think it's gonna be
it's gonna be good for our relationship
for our marriage and for our home in
general maybe you'll see each other
better
Felix like frames are handcrafted with
the same high quality materials used in
high-end designer frames like organic
Italian acetate and German engineered
steel their glasses are available and
non-prescription prescription and
readers as well as kids and adult sizes
so even if you don't have bad eyes but
you just want to protect your eyes from
like the treacherous Ness of the blue
light you can get a non prescription
glasses but just like such a trendy
thing to do and you remember room needs
to do that growing up you have to like
layers yeah yeah yeah Claire's ones
we're not good for our eyes for sure
yeah don't go another day looking at
screens without the hope help of some
Felix grace go to Felix GRA GRA Y
glasses dot-com / toast for free
shipping in 30 days of risk-free returns
or exchanges that's Felix gray glasses
dot-com sesh toast again that's great
with an A Felix GRA GRA Y glasses comm /
toast sign-on protect your eyes feel see
amazing okay that's our Paradise
bathroom holidays will recap tomorrow on
the snatchler but just my overall
thought it was a tough episode it took
us 45 minutes to get the rose torture
and I honestly like that fight was
really stupid and honestly like justice
for Christian he literally didn't do
anything wrong
yeah but no he needed violently Jordan
was stupid but then Christian like put
hated it so they were both in the wrong
they were both in the wrong but from the
beginning the Christian didn't do
anything wrong he came to Paradis and
saw someone he liked like all these guys
like hating him because clay like to
call - Nicole went along with it like he
didn't do anything I agree and Jordan
coming over and instigating with the
what was it was stupid and immature and
instigate a Christian definitely made it
more violent by like putting hands on
boat Jordan literally picked him up and
body slammed him like that was a whole
other level of the island so they both
needed to go at that big well thing you
should go but if they had to pick one
person to go home it should have been
Jordan oh I think they would have sent
home Christian because what Jordan did
was like technically like what he threw
the teddy bear in the ocean like that
didn't because Clayton become a fight it
was just like a petty thing to do and he
was doing that again and this show runs
on petty [ __ ] so like he wasn't doing
anything off-book I was really surprised
that they were just like very like
teacher you both go home you know yeah
well after last lassies season it had -
honestly I'm so glad that they both went
home and they were both probably going
home anyway yeah um so I wasn't upset
about it and then Kristina just being
such a loser like giving Blake a rose
like and she thinks she's like this
dojin is like I want him to watch Hannah
and Dylan fall in love stupid like she's
so [ __ ] stupid and it was worth it
she's not just like stupid and like
stupid to be super dangerous she thinks
she's a genius right no no she was
really frustrating me to watch and
honestly like I was watching the episode
being like oh my god I hate Nicole but
then I like tweeted something I Nicole
and she tweeted back unless she could
have been mean and she wasn't so now I
respect for her for like being able to
laugh at herself like every time I've
tweet like his gone viral about her like
and it is a little like funny about her
she could be like a weeny bit mean to me
but she's taking it and rolling with the
punches and accepting the Twitter
followers like gracefully and I really
respect that I just I have to put it out
there like I respect the hell out of
Nicole uh Lopez yeah that's yeah that's
a cool thing to do ya know it's very
brave I can't I can't say that I would
do the same what else happened
um Demi and Derrick are falling apart
falling apart it's like sad to watch Oh
1111 make away oh also what's happening
is the greatest relationship of all time
may be the Romeo and Juliet of our
generation Jean Paul Jones at Asia
I completely agree and you know who John
Paul Jones reminds me of who Grizz yes
from the society because most like he's
like a he appears like be a jock and but
then he's like so learning and in in
touch with his emotions and he's just so
much more than he seems to me and he's
like amazing you know and like that
scene I'm so glad that they played that
entire scene like it was a very long
conversation before they jumped in the
pool they were sitting on and like it
was like a weird conversation but it was
like so playful and so cute and like it
was a feel like people don't get that
much airtime usually but they showed the
whole conversation front to end where
they jumped in the pool and it was the
best conversation I was like a giddy
twelve-year-old watching it no I love
them and I've been saying I sanitation
Derek but now I Santa Sarah and John
Paul Jones especially because I just
love when guys like they like someone
and they're obsessed with them and
they're not gonna stray in there and
they're so grateful for these women
giving them the time of day right and
that they should that's why I like every
person who's being like Dylan is clingy
like you're an [ __ ] because girls
love to be like I won't give a nice guy
like all these guys do sh baggies and
then they see Dylan who has a very clear
agenda
he only wants Hannah and Hannah alone
forever and ever till the day he dies
and everyone painting is like he's crazy
clinger like no that's what girls want
so stop asking for it if you don't
actually want it I agree that it's cute
but
it's not as cute when it's like I mean I
really like them and so I don't even
want to say anything negative but like
when it's Hannah G and she's like
clearly like the number one girl in this
group it's not so like romantic when
someone's like obsessed with her and
gonna do everything to Piper it's not
romantic but I don't think it's weird
people are making it seem like he's a
freak
yeah it's not free I'm glad they finally
like found their ground oh by the way
some of the women in paradise like you
can see the way they talk in their
testimonials are so [ __ ] jealous of
Hanan like I would be too it's like if
you just came there and all these guys
literally five guys are obsessed with
Hannah like no one's there for you like
it's really annoying but the way they
like Sydney and like some of the women
talk about Hannah like they [ __ ] hate
her yeah it's my treat so [ __ ]
annoying
nobody is annoying that's what I felt on
Yenko she's like there's two guys here
and four girls and they've all had sex
with each other and like I don't feel
included and like what am I doing here
and her michio people were saying it was
selfish if or not to give a rose to like
wills or someone who was too fat [ __ ]
that
go home [ __ ] you know and we need to
cycle these people out those guys there
who aren't getting a rose have now been
there for two weeks
yeah and they've made no connections
there's been a lot of premium girls
coming through and you know what I don't
see it happening for you like if you
couldn't make a good like the first
people that come are the best people
it's not gonna get much better from here
except Jenn Saab is coming next week and
I [ __ ] stand yeah I wasn't sure if
she was coming I wasn't sure if she was
coming but if I thought she was coming
they would for sure address the fact
that her and Blake went on a date I
think they're going to they have to I
didn't see it in the trailer there was
only so much they could give us and I
think they also like don't want to show
us some stone stairs broke the news like
months ago when like so many rumors
about Blake were swirling he was spotted
somewhere by a toaster in actually she
lives there that means that he once
again used his frequent flyers longer
visit someone from the franchise and
make connections before paradise and he
went on the tip of jets Ave and never
really got written up in everywhere but
the toasters [ __ ] founded and that
picture resurfaced last night in the
toasters Facebook group because it's so
crazy
they better address it I said they have
T they're dressing everything you know
he's not getting away with nothing yeah
and so I think the gents Ave on top of
the Kaitlyn I'm a doll now he would be
up to like seven girls that he's been
mingling with that might finish him well
what was so interesting is I was
actually really surprised at how to
chose Dylan because you know I'm no body
language expert but I was watching
there's ninety percent the cheese stayed
and then the mariachi date and Hannah
was so much more carefree comfortable
like more
she more forward with Blake and like
every time Dylan caster should pull
dawei and I gave the cheek like I really
thought for sure she was gonna choose
Blake I didn't think she was gonna
choose like because she's concerned with
her image but I agree that it just from
what we saw and I know we don't see
everything but from what we saw it looks
like she was just more interested and
had more chemistry with Blake yeah and
even at the date after she made decision
that date with all the Aztec dancers she
still didn't seem like she did with
Blake you know it's like like Dylan has
her head but like Blake has her heart
and she went with her head which is like
what we're all like supposed to do and
she's doing what she's supposed to do
and maybe it will turn into like real
true I I don't think it's true love I
think I just really like Dylan and I'd
like appreciate him being a good guy and
going after the most sought-after girl
in paradise and having a real chance at
it you know yeah I'm like happy for him
but he's like the honor doesn't wanna
make you scream but I don't think that
they're really a match made in heaven
I don't yeah I agree because I feel like
she has a wandering eye because this is
the prime of like you know it wasn't
just an instant connection love at first
sight she's done she's closing every
other door I think her eyes are still
like wait who's coming juggy Kristin
Cavallari for girls in Nashville I was
thinking that but she has her own show
why would she do that
yeah well cuz maybe the show would
actually be good there you have Larry is
now getting a third season which means
that doesn't mean it's good it means
there's right it needs people like it
shows only get cancelled for one reason
so true you said it yourself I did say
it I love and you can quote me back
AE okay let's see the reference not sure
we'll watch the rest of the show tonight
yes and below deck Oh below deck you
know just such a good show I like I
never forget I never remember what day
it's on but it's like I'm always
watching TV and then it's like the new
episode of below deck and was just like
so excited to see it it's just such a
consistent like funny happy sad like
it's just a good show it's an all-around
show oh my gosh you guys have to watch
the patreon episode of Asbury Park I
don't want to say what we talked about
but it's pretty interesting what related
to oh did you did you talk about it yeah
we did cuz we were in the car oh my god
wait it's subscribe to the patron and
watch this video just for that moment
because I don't know if we're gonna do
it well talking about it after the video
um oh my stomach just rumbled I wonder
if you could hear the episode was kind
of boring like every time I
fast-forwarded through commercials I was
like oh my god it's only been like this
short no but this charter crew was the
Charter group on the
was funny they were funny and I think
they had a good time but I liked and
they didn't tip just throwing up
that was crazy oh my god that was the
craziest thing I ever saw like Howie why
does he show us so much Farrah I don't
know and he almost threw up on aja aja
but then he ended up throwing up on one
of the camera guys cuz there's another
terrible cuz it was below deck yeah it's
so sad so terrible but they shouldn't
have been showing us the throw up on the
rail for so long like yeah come on come
on I'm really struggling between life I
actually really like and respect you and
I was watching him watch off inside last
night it was a rerun but he basically
was like such an [ __ ] last season and
Andy was like what happened like you're
like much better this season he was like
seeing myself on TV like being such a
prick was like so humbling and like
really like I grew up so much and I just
really like liked him and respect him I
think he really likes his job and he
really wants to grow and I'd be a
captain but I feel like he's being so
unnecessarily hard on Jaclyn I disagree
really I think he's like trying to
handle jack with clay clubs and I think
jack is [ __ ] terrible
he's so annoying he doesn't do his job
what are you doing here he's like dead
weight on this boat and like what's
worse is that everyone loves him and so
you I was like not even being as neat
like if everyone hated jack then jus I
would could be even meaner to him but
it's like this person who sucks at their
job and it only affects me but everyone
else likes him so if I mean to him like
I'm on the outs with the group I'm the
only one not in the relationship he
takes his job really seriously and Jack
is like just a like he seems like a cool
dude but like he's not a worker bee yeah
but it's just like he's felt like being
so nitpicky like when Jack was cleaning
the rails and he came out it was I mean
he's not about you getting fired because
he was like not cleaning the whole rail
but like parts of it where there were
spots I don't know it just seemed like
he was really looking for a reason to
yell at him no captain teeny said go out
there and give it to him he looks like
he was gassed by the captain tanning
cabin today is not like the most fierce
leader like she's very much a doormat no
I think it's a bigger like the obviously
the rails wasn't the first or second or
third thing and so when you're in front
of the captain and you're still fake
cleaning what the [ __ ] are you doing
what are you doing when you're not in
front of a second also I'm you know what
I really like I've taken a turn a
negative turn on anesthesia yes she
never should have accepted the chef's
job she obviously couldn't handle it
like it was cool and when they were in a
pickle but when they docked and had a
new charter guess they should have
gotten a new chef captain's handy that
was her biggest mistake honestly she
can't handle it the ham the hair not
okay and she
doesn't take responsibility for anything
and like you should know this was the
craziest thing she ever said I'm not
responsible for what happens when the
dition leaves my galley and goes up to
the the table like if it gets cold in
that journey then that's not my thought
because it was hot when it left my
kitchen
it's a ten-second walk there's no way I
stay close from hot to cold yeah and
then like her plating and like making
everyone run like and not telling anyone
who the well-done steaks were yes this
like there are tons of ships in the Med
that have chefs that get hot food out
like you just didn't learn how to make
food hot includes you're not a chef
because you're not but like you had to
just be like I don't know what I don't
know it's on me not because they're
walking too slowly
yeah and Hannah's definitely getting
like a little it's weird for like
someone who was two levels below you now
to be your equal
and I was definitely like looking for
things wrong like she literally said to
the guy who who had the well-done steak
who it wasn't done well done but she
went up to him was I do want this cooked
more he didn't ask well she probably saw
that it wasn't cooking he was sure for
sure for sure for sure she's doing her
time also like they're correct in saying
like the food makes the tip like better
if you have bad food but good service
like it's not gonna be a great
experience if you have a great food and
mediocre service you'll get a better tip
and like it's about the food and till
she's like being critical of anesthesia
it's because that's affecting her wallet
Jackie when they were like the hairs
just it wasn't mine like how do you know
that but also that's not the way to
respond right oh my god I'm so sorry she
immediately went on the defense this job
is not for her and I'm really looking
forward to her being debunked back down
to you a third stew
but captain sandy was once again in a
pickle because now she has two third
stews and she has to let someone go and
I didn't think that it should be Jews I
couldn't agree more
and I know June's not like the best
third stew but first of all she's like
the nicest person to ever go on reality
TV I think she's the newest to the boat
like it takes time not everyone is gonna
learn everything that second yeah and
like anytime Hannah's told her or
something like she fixes in and she does
it she's always talking and doing
laundry which seems to me like the worst
job third to always just longish but
she's always actively working yeah she
doesn't complain like I just and why
does she beep get punished because of
Anastasia's like flip-flopping I
couldn't agree more
I think honest Asia should have went
home I don't know what the right thing
to do was but I mean Colin's gonna come
in and save the day and like I ship calm
and I hope it she gives him a big fat
kiss no I can open he gives her his
godliness like such a nice guy I'm
watching up inside which wasn't last
night but they replayed it he was saying
how likes he gets so many moms in his
DMS like asking to date his daughters
and and he was like what's your type and
he goes I just like people who like me
back
how [ __ ] sad is that horrible thing
you've ever heard it's the most pathetic
thing I've ever heard no but you know
what I kind of feel him I feel like
growing up I used to be that way cuz I
was like if you like me means you have
good taste
critic you know you like me you must be
funny yeah and smart yeah you must be a
[ __ ] genius to know that I'm it right
after why wouldn't I go out with a
genius yeah that's a great girl so I
can't yeah okay anyways June June Hannah
I'm gonna miss her I know and you know
what it's like she really gave this
season like Bravo's now shot by Bravo
selling merch with June June Hannah like
she created and June June Hannah has
literally taken over Twitter like she
created this viral woman like she got
fired yeah I think she'd have to keep
her job I also loved how she handled
when she did get fired because she
didn't just like take it and be a
doormat but she also wasn't
disrespectful she was just like that's
not nice
it's no it's also it's really not fair
yeah she did
you have fired when you do something
wrong and the girls like saying the
dream teams back together so mean I just
I it was so not ready reminds me of
season one below deck where Kate Cheston
and that girl Kat we're so [ __ ] me to
the scroller you mean who was just like
this a nice southern girl who like she
wasn't cool and like they didn't really
get along the other two girls were much
closer they were so [ __ ] neater like
the fact that this girl ended up coming
back on another season a below deck was
shocking like they were talking [ __ ]
about her right in front of her face
like it was so me and so evil like
that's what it reminds me of Wow also we
didn't talk about Trevor stopping
Anastasia in the face which was just
like he's gotta go and at what point is
what you do off the boat affect your job
you really like [ __ ] in yeah but it
really um hold on it really was
confusing me because remember when chef
Mila was saying all those crazy things
he was like so like the moral compass in
the car like really like I was like yes
you go Trevor I like loved him and like
how you could be two different people is
crazy crazy that's reality TV though in
a sentence
yeah but also like alcoholism yeah yeah
it was honestly like a really I mean it
was
unfortunately thing that happened but
the way that this show handled it it was
a really good mini lesson and like this
is like what this is problematic but it
doesn't always look problematic on its
face yeah you know yeah okay so we're
back tomorrow and then also we will be
dropping this week's episode of the
snatchler tomorrow afternoon so make
sure to find us on Spotify until we're
back up and running on iTunes don't you
sure to get Santa make sure they get
snatched cuz that's all listening to the
morning shows the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
that Spotify iTunes stitcher public
radio literally anywhere you can find so
leave a five star subscription there we
actually could use in the subscription
so head over there so we can use some
subscriptions reviews let's just let's
get it up be positive you know yeah
that's all I'm saying it's positive
vibes yeah love you guys so much have a
great day we'll see you tomorrow bye
you